auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge tag eins im neuen leben von
auswanderer marco schon die chance
verabschiedeten sich in der letzten
folge von ihren verwandten und freunden
in der schweiz in ruanda wollen sie ein
fitness studio eröffnen
[Musik]
familie kappus räumte ihr haus im
emmental ein über 100 jahre alter
wasserturm an der nordsee ist ihr
projekt für die zukunft
und auf und davon nach spanien gingen
green und ralf waldburger und in
sonnigen süden planen sie ein hundehotel
[Musik]
in bennys an der costa blanca wird es
morgen mehr als 300 tage pro jahr
scheint hier die sonne
vor gut zwölf stunden sind greenwald
wurde und ihr mann ralf in spanien
angekommen
die erste nacht verbrachten sie im pool
haus das neue heim scheint karte caruso
noch nicht ganz geheuer zu sein
[Musik]
die schweizer haben das anwesen vor
wenigen monaten gekauft jetzt können sie
6600 quadratmeter land ihr eigen nennen
darauf stehen zwei häuser das pool und
das wohnhaus
praktisch und zwei sachen kraftwerk
fertig ist
[Musik]
die kaffeemaschine ist vom vorbesitzer
reif und seine frau haben das inventar
übernommen
wir stellen
[Musik]
die neue heimat zeigt sich für
waldburger von ihrer besten seite
[Musik]
wer den tag am meer beginnen kann darf
sich glücklich schätzen
in cuxhaven ist das möglich
[Musik]
während die stadt langsam erwacht
erreichen zwei autos mit schweizer
kennzeichen jetzt familie kapuze hat die
nacht auf der autobahn verbracht
rund 1000 kilometer sind es vom emmental
bis an die nordsee ein mehrfamilienhaus
in der nähe des stadtzentrums
hier befindet sich die neue wohnung der
familie mir appel und alle haben sie bei
ihrem letzten besuch in cuxhaven
entdeckt und gleich gemietet
1400 quadratmetern viel weniger als in
langnau
dort besaß die familie ein großes
einfamilienhaus
ab jetzt müssen sie zusammenrücken so
lange bis der wasserturm fertig ist vom
berner mittelland an den äußersten
zipfel deutschlands ans wattenmeer
fischerei und tourismus prägen cuxhaven
eine stadt mit gut 50.000 einwohnern
[Musik]
ursprünglich wollte die familie direkt
in den wasserturm ziehen in eine
provisorische renovierte wohnung im
erdgeschoss aber der baubeginn
verzögerte sich
kabul us mussten nach einer alternative
suchen
das hab ich was dir was auch so und
wiederum hatte demnach kritisieren mit
und da ist einmal der it-manager wir
vorurteilen auf
[Gelächter]
ich glaube ja sozusagen locker machen
sie geld der aktion aktiv erschlagen
[Musik]
knapp südlich des äquators auf 1500
meter über dem meer liegt kigali in der
hauptstadt ruandas ist das neue zuhause
von diana und ihrem mann marc o
[Musik]
die an ist ohne ihren mann vorausgereist
vier wochen ist sie schon hier und
bereitet alles für die gemeinsame
auswanderung vor spott
raum schauen vor der sport fitness platz
seit ihrer ankunft sucht die zumba
trainerin nach einem geeigneten ort für
ihr fitnessstudio mehrere immobilien hat
sie bereits besichtigt das problem
geschäftsflächen in guter lage sind rar
die stadt wächst ständig und die
nachfrage ist groß
[Musik]
seite heute okay jetzt schluss irgendwie
war zimmer sind aber die schöne finden
[Musik]
die räumlichkeiten müssen von der größe
passen aber auch fürs budget
neben geräten für kraft- und
ausdauertraining möchte die 49-jährige
auch verschiedene kurse anbieten
maximal 2.000 dollar miete kann sie im
monat bezahlen
vielleicht kann ein base waren die
geldpolitisch dann geht es ans
eingemachte
also im monat 5000 dollar
das heißt viel
gaddafi
zu teuer die an muss weiter suchen
[Musik]
welches ohne kinder zu nutzen um green
und ralf wollen so schnell wie möglich
mit dem bau ihres hunde hotels beginnen
doch zuerst müssen sie ihr wohnhaus
renovieren so genau dort waren da nicht
wirklich wie möbel nicht mehr in der
sonne lieber modern gern würde die
schlafzimmer in stille vor diesem
monument 100 schachteln zwei sideboards
und ein metallgestell mehr haben sie
nicht aus der schweiz mitgebracht was
von den vorhandenen möbeln noch
brauchbar ist wollen sie behalten
den rest kaufen sie neu
die vorgaben halten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ralf hat wohin im internet kennengelernt
sie ist seine zweite frau eineinhalb
jahre wohnten sie im thurgau zusammen
bis zur auswanderung wohlfühlt aber sich
auch wunderschön jetzt das meeres neues
gemeinsam kunst machen ein anderer land
wo alles für uns beide und fürs big
business für uns beide besuchs bauen das
sich schönes gefühl
die beiden wollen die schatten der
vergangenheit hinter sich lassen
[Musik]
dabei stellen bisher ist es jedoch nur
ein traum
das hundehotel unter spanischer sonne
dafür haben sie in der schweiz alles
aufgegeben
das gemeinsame haus die sicheren jobs
und ihren freundeskreis
[Musik]
tja haus auch nutzer der rücken schmerzt
zwar noch aber mirabellen und allein
können nicht länger warten
sie wollen zum wasser ton und nachsehen
ob dort alles in ordnung ist schon
mehrfach haben vandalen den leer
stehenden turm beschädigt vor vier
monaten waren sie das letzte mal hier
damals hatten sie ihre pläne mit den
architekten besprochen
die luft ist abgestanden aber sonst
scheint alles in ordnung zu sein
die schweizer wollen den 46 meter hohen
turm komplett umbauen
neben einem bed and breakfast mit sechs
zimmern soll ein café entstehen dazu
ihre eigene wohnung
doch die architekten kommen mit den
plänen für das baugesuch nicht voran
es hängt am brandschutz der turm ist zu
hoch für die leiter der feuerwehr die
deutsche treppenlift wo es große sie das
macht sofort durch mehrfaches und was
mit das was ich habe so eine rund fünf
kubikmeter wird springt und mit
kompressor ist was alles dazugehört und
das sek und das jetzt schon gestört
so vereinbarte leistung und der ich
stehe hier nicht dass die aktion wie
werk
[Applaus]
die zusätzlichen auflagen machen das
projekt viel teurer
dabei glaubten bus saß bestens
vorbereitet zu sein
schon vor dem kauf des turms im jahr
2017 hatten sie sich von experten
beraten lassen und ihr vorhaben mit den
behörden diskutiert trotz genauer
planung der umbau ist viel komplizierter
als gedacht
der kini rongo market ein geschäftiges
durcheinander im herzen kigali
thoma
dallas
die ankommt nicht gerne hierher
sie kauft lieber in kleinen läden ein
doch heute ist alles anders die an
braucht lebensmittel für das willkommens
fest dass sie für ihren mann marco
organisiert anders als beim
grossverteiler in der schweiz wird deren
der einkauf zum auto getragen
eine annehmlichkeit und die sich schnell
gewöhnt auch sonst sieht die an in
ruanda mehr möglichkeiten
25 jahre nach ihrer flucht befindet sich
das land im aufschwung
als in der schweiz also bot gibt ich bin
immer vorne dabei
heute sehen
[Musik]
zurück in kanada in einem wohnquartier
des unteren mittelstands hier hat die an
ein möbliertes haus gemietet
zwei köche und die als beste freundin
helfen vorbereiten
20 leute hat sie zur party eingeladen
[Musik]
da ich die branche von fleisch
für den gemeinsamen start in ruanda soll
alles perfekt sein
[Musik]
naja freude dass ich nun mehr alleine
bin ja so viel zeit alleine kann und das
ist nicht es ist mühsam wochenende
alleine unter woche alleine
ich freue mich dass ich jemand daran
dass markt kommt
[Musik]
und dann ist es soweit marco kommt in
kigali an
die heimat seiner frau kennt der 51
jährige ingenieur gut aus vielen
gemeinsamen ferien zu gerne stelle alle
sitze mit der frau eines bier trinkt da
freuen wir jetzt einfach ist 80
kompliziert
[Musik]
worldcom wohl kaum noch ahnt marco nicht
was ihn erwartet
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
22 jahre verheiratet und verliebt fest
wie am ersten tag
[Musik]
ich bin
[Gelächter]
die an hat nicht nur verwandte und
freunde zusammengetrommelt
auch die nachbarn sind gekommen eine
woche ist familie kabus inzwischen in
cuxhaven und für einmal geht es bei
ihnen nicht um den wasserturm
die sommerferien sind zu ende
jannis und sein bruder nicola müssen in
die schule
das ist normal
jeder beruf hat janis startet in die
achte klasse der realschule aus gold
sein bruder geht neu auf die
berufsbildung schule
mit seinen jungs hatte am vorabend noch
telefoniert jetzt muss er sich in bern
auf seinen job konzentrieren
ich bin prima in zehn minuten öffnet
diese index eine technologie messe aller
ist messeleiter und als chef für den
reibungslosen ablauf der veranstaltung
verantwortlich
[Musik]
allah hat seine festanstellung bereits
gekündigt als selbstständige wird er
seine dienste jedoch weiter anbieten
nur so kommen tabus in cuxhaven über die
runden
eine journalistin von den geistern
nachrichten ist auf die auswanderer aus
der ostschweiz aufmerksam geworden
sie will einen bericht schreiben über
green und ralf und deren pläne für das
hundehotel die hotels sind so element
bauten die wir durch einen schweizer
architekt kaufen können und die kann man
dann liebig er weist aber wir möchten
natürlich das haus nicht so wie sie
jetzt hier ist dieses eigentlich platten
nennen des ausklangs kleidung mit
holzplatten und garniert farbe gemalt
die bilden werden also dass es nachher
wirklich wie ein hotel aus es sieht
danach aus wie ein schweizer chalet
sechs verschiedene themen zimmer für
insgesamt zwölf hunde wollen sie bauen
darf möchte dabei so viel wie möglich
selber machen haben wir dann die
einfahrt für die kunden dann wird es
hier parkplätze geben
dieses teil sie hat angebaut mit dem
regen hundehotel also wir da hinten zum
nachbarn bis zu den massen wer das ganze
grundstück für die hunde seien mit
spielwiese und wenn sie schon kontakt zu
den nachbarn gehabt die nachbarn die
nachbarn erhalten auch einen brief von
der gemeinde war also sie haben also sie
hat ja so ausgeschrieben noch die die
baugebiete also der bau 20 tage lang
also die nachbarn werden noch informiert
das ist das nächste jahr das wäre die
nachbarn begrüßen
noch ist caruso allein geht es nach
waldburg es wird sich das rasch ändern
schon in sechs monaten wollen sie ihr
hundehotel eröffnen
[Musik]
durchschnittstemperatur 22 grad das
ganze jahr hindurch
der neue alltag für schommers in kigali
viel zeit die angenehmen seiten ruandas
zu genießen haben sie nicht sie müssen
räume finden für das fitnessstudio und
ein haus in dem sie in zukunft wohnen
können
jetzt sollten wir mal wurde container
steckt das freiluft büro marco und die
ahnen haben ihren gesamten hausrat nach
ruanda verschifft und die geräte für das
fitnessstudio und information so gut die
news der container hat bereits drei
wochen verspätung in daressalam und das
datum 27 12 heißt die unter häuschen im
koffer eine vitale ich hab einfach angst
dass der container noch wie später
synchro ja weil du musst du dann auch
einen erfahrungen mit dem mit dem
fitness oder also mit du hast ja nachher
jetzt bin ich richtig ein ganzes
installiert ist
ja das ist sicher newsnetz
[Musik]
der wasserturm gehört schon fest zum
neuen leben der covus auch wenn sie von
der umsetzung ihres projektes noch weit
entfernt sind
bhp hat per mail ein erstes angebot
bekommen für einen größeren lift ist
machbar ist und verschiedene englische
ordner um ordner haben sie inzwischen
angesammelt
doch über die planungsphase kommen die
auswanderer bisher nicht hinaus
der erste schultag ist zu ende
wir machen trotzdem lehnen die günstig
gräbt der schau automatisch xxl so
automatisch beruhigt ja
eine sorge weniger
zumindest bei janis und nicola läuft
alles nach plan
[Musik]
in spanien machen sich waldburger star
andere pendenzen liste abzuarbeiten
corinnas mutter marian unterstützt sie
dabei auf dem rathaus in bennys wollen
sich die neuankömmlinge registrieren
[Musik]
an der costa blanca leben collins eltern
bereits seit 15 jahren
sie schätzen das milde klima und die
günstigen lebenshaltungskosten genau wie
tausende andere auswanderer aus
mitteleuropa corinne und ralf brauchen
eine wohnsitz bestätigung nur so können
sie später die aufenthaltsbewilligung
beantragen
die frau berichtete wird endlich wieder
ein wohnsitz korrekt ist
das geburtstagsgeschenk bitte jetzt
offiziell alles tipptopp bei waldburger
es läuft es wie geschmiert
[Musik]
in ruanda bekommen die solothurner
auswanderer besuch den pastor hat die an
organisiert womit sie das alles gut geht
das ist die projekt gekümmert und zu
wiegen also für das ist letztlich 6
[Musik]
chance erhalten den segen nicht einfach
irgendwo pastor innocence möchte zu
einem kraftort eine autostunde von
kigali entfernt sofern ein wasserfall
mehr
das können wir sofort bauen
der weg zum wasserfall ist versperrt
doch so schnell geben die drei nicht auf
waren berühmt hat 3
diese hat es hingehauen dort ist
gefährlich
du bist du glücklich und wenn wir vom
dorf her locker man tötet seinen weg vom
dorf selbst eine am fluss entlang
noch ein letzter versuch
[Musik]
nein hier geht was
und siehe da
aber da ist ja
vielleicht ahnen ist schon was bereits
den segen des pastors können sie noch
gut gebrauchen
[Musik]
das bio am bodensee aufgewachsen und was
soll ich schon ein wichtiges element und
der kunde wenn man schon irgendwie
speziell buchs
aber da ich begann die stadt nein
galt mit dem genial die facc hat es ralf
angetan
jetzt in den ersten gemeinsamen ferien
mit corinne war für ihn klar
hier möchte er irgendwann leben
[Musik]
oder so spricht eigentlich unglaublich
bis vor kurzem war ralf noch chef über
das ersatzteillager in einem autohaus
und corinne arbeitete als
sachbearbeiterin in einem
industriebetrieb
wir sind guten mutes und unterblieben
brach das gut laufe
positiv denken und noch ein verbot des
problems und einfach kann man das auch
dem moment wenn es denn so richter
machen wir uns gedanken was können sie
was wir uns nicht wenn da und da das
weiß meliert das weiß wieso ist in jedem
level genauso wie kein problem
das geht nur lösung
nach blicken wald borders voller
zuversicht in die zukunft
[Musik]
und marco haben nur noch wenige wochen
zeit ein neues haus für sich in kigali
zu finden
dann müssen sie aus ihrer bisherigen
bleibe ausziehen
eine vermittlerin zeigt ihnen
verschiedene möglichkeiten zum einen die
spitze der balkon schlecht einfach die
tätig das sind ein wahnsinn über die
massiv regie geführt hat
kein schutz vor den fenstern aber jeden
stiegen
das ist vor dem parkplatz eigene knüppel
doch ein spezieller fahrer genug
[Musik]
das haus hat fünf schlafzimmer und
kostet 1200 dollar im monat
ein hoher preis für das was es bietet
[Musik]
also ich bin nicht zufrieden sagte
stieler
um ein cabrio
nächste woche auf und davon
baustelle pur
thomas finden in ruanda passende
räumlichkeiten aber innerhalb weniger
wochen muss aus der ehemaligen bar ein
fitnessstudio werden dass das verdeck
ich weiß nie
in spanien gibt es bei wahlburgers
probleme mit der baubewilligung für das
hundehotel die nachbarn wehren sich
gegen die pläne der schweizer komisches
gefühl wenn du und an der nordsee stockt
die planung mit dem wasserturm nach wie
vor familie kabul will jedoch nicht mehr
länger warten muss nicht kommen
[Musik]
christoph
auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge